we already know that president biden
sent five million barrels from the spr
to foreign countries including to china
but since then the news has only gotten
more disturbing tonight we can report
about exactly who inside china was a
direct beneficiary the free beacon is
reporting that 950 000 of those barrels
went to unipec a trading arm of the
china petrochemical corporation now that
company commonly known as sinopec is
wholly owned by the chinese government
meanwhile of course ccp now here now is
daniel turner founder of power the
future daniel
i i keep saying this is beyond
disturbing the words don't even capture
this at this point
tell us why this matters there's also a
biden connection to sign up
yeah this is disturbing on multiple
levels to start with the president told
us he was releasing these reserves to
lower the price of gas nationally and
then you find out that he through
secretary grand home of the department
of energy is selling them around on the
world market and selling them to the
communist chinese so a we're selling our
strategic raw materials our strategic
reserves to the communist country who's
our adversary and then you find out one
of the companies that was brokering this
deal
one of our top investors is of course
hunter biden so the sun the president's
reprobate crackhead son is invested in a
company that is buying our strategic
reserves while we're paying more than
five dollars a gallon at the pump if we
had a an impeachment hearing about a
phone call with donald trump and
president zielinski if this doesn't
cause jerry nadler and it doesn't cause
adam's ship to ask some questions and
for congress to do its job and wonder
how this biden crime family is profiting
while the american people are suffering
i don't understand if there is a more uh
offense that is more worthy of
investigating for impeachment let's put
it that way well where where where's the
new york times on this
where's the jeff bezos washington post
on this i mean
yeah this is a
massive story
and people ask if the biden
administration the biden family is owned
by china because they're about to lift
the tariffs too we know that
i mean i don't know what you say about
this i mean if they're not owned by
china they're acting like they're owned
by china
and and the president also used the
defense authorization act using military
powers to commandeer the purchase of
wind and solar that are also made in
china so thank goodness for the free
beacon colin anderson who wrote the
story deserves a shadow because they
broke a major story but but i'm getting
angry at this laura for very personal
reasons because this president just last
week questioned our patriotism the press
secretary said that we were not
upholding our american standards we've
been told that we're shills of vladimir
putin because we the big bad oil and gas
company aren't lowering prices we were
accused of price gouging profiteering
and then you find out his administration
is selling oil on the world stage and
potentially his own family is profiting
from it and that is beyond offensive i
would like to thank senator manchin and
senator barrasso who head the energy
natural resources committee i'd like to
think they would haul secretary granholm
who who's in charge of this as the
department of energy secretary and ask
her some really tough questions we're
paying five dollars a gallon because of
this administration's energy policies
and now his family is potentially
profiting on the world market it's it's
unpatriotic and it's shameful and it's
potentially criminal yeah
meanwhile he's beating up the and
mom-and-pop gas stations i mean this was
the great part of this i mean
by the way i got to play this from the
economic advisor at the white house
brian deese he insisted
that the president is focused on
lowering gas prices watch
we have to show
action
on behalf of the american people and
that's exactly what the president is
doing and every day he's focused on
practical things that he can do so the
release of oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve sounds esoteric to
people but you know oil market analysts
you've had on this show will say it was
single-handedly responsible for keeping
oil prices going higher
daniel why did he send it to other
countries especially china that is
buying oil from russia that is fighting
the war in ukraine that we're fighting a
proxy war against
well that's exactly it they're caught in
a complete lie they're telling us
they're releasing the strategic reserve
to lower prices domestically and you
find out they're actually not bringing
it to american refineries they're
selling it on the world market so
they're in an absolute lie and secondly
yes the sanction of russian oil this
moral duty that we have to sanction
russian oil all it has done is force a
greater alliance between russia and
china so china's already profiting from
russian oil at a premium and now they're
profiting from american oil as well it's
just it's an administration that is part
of or brian diese had this crazy phrase
the new liberal world order this is part
of the liberal world order but it is not
what the american people want and boy
this election this is this is an issue
that is on the ballot this november no
doubt
daniel great to see you thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else